[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today up next
we've got bill in New Haven Connecticut
Bill how's it
going hi thank you for taking my call
sure um my wife and I are in a very
difficult
situation I'm 71 I'll be 72 next month
my wife is 66 she teaches at a private
school we moved
from uh a state where the salaries are
considerably lower than they are here in
Connecticut and the cost of living is
not a whole lot
different
and um this past summer and the Heat of
the summer for Connecticut our air
conditioning went out
completely and it's going to cost us
almost
14,500 to get a new uh furnace and
everything uh um to replace the one that
went that went out and uh that's going
to we they have a state program here I
can Finance it'll be almost one be about
a 175 a month for 10 years additionally
my wife took out a parent loan for our
daughter to go to college I was
adamantly opposed to it
but you know her philosophy is she's my
baby and I love her so I'm going to do
it and due to being in forbearance twice
once due to being to getting sick and
having to take off work during the
school year in the other state and
um and then
moving uh up here to
Connecticut uh she went into forbearance
each of those two times and what that
means is that you don't have to make a a
payment but the interest AC crws MH as a
result she still owes over
$100,000 on that yes our daughter went
to a private school in New
York and uh yes uh it's like I've been
fighting a losing battle financially all
these years and I'm 71 now I'll be 72
next
month and I have to go back to
work um you know I took an early
retirement a few years ago but you know
all I'm getting is a small social
security check because my salaries were
always low I have a a small Army Reserve
retirement thank goodness I stayed in
that for over 20 years and then I have a
very very small State retirement from
our most recent State I worked for the
State Retirement System uh for a few
years so what is what do the household
income add up to right
now our total
income our AGI is less than 100,000
okaying
everything and my wife is 66 and she
would like to start receiving Social
Security when she can get the maximum
dollar amount and I would like for her
to do that too but she's talking about
starting to receive Social Security as
soon as she can which I believe is
about another six or months or so
something like
that and uh it would be considerably
less and she teaches at a private school
now she's happy though the salaries at
private schools are very
low but she says at her age if she were
to get a Connecticut teaching
certificate nobody would hire her
because who wants a who wants a uh 66y
old buy that one well that's what she
says and uh plus she she loves where she
is now she was in a miserable teaching
situation uh in the previous state
that's why she went on sick leave
because
the superintendent drove her to that to
make a long story short and then we
moved up here and so due to those two
situations why she went on the
forbearance because we did not have any
money coming in to make the payments now
I'm looking at at going back to work
whether it's full-time or part-time
preferably full-time because like I said
I need the money well how much do you
guys have that's liquid liquid
cash we have bills up to our eyeballs
you have more debt than the parent Plus
loans and this 145 HVAC yes what else
yes credit cards of course and it's
about
$70,000 goodness gracious yes I know I
know it's it's horrifying and I'm is
your wife concerned about this or is it
just you absolutely yes both of us are
concerned and what other
debt well the house what's left on the
mortgage oh gee
probably about well 200 and something
thousand okay what's the house
worth
uh I don't know we're not sure about
that it's
about what' you buy it
for I'm trying to remember we bought it
for 3,000 and something 300,000 and
something okay uh now I'm like I said
I'm looking at going back to work and I
know that some of the places I've come
across mention in their ads that they
offer
401ks some mention that they offer 401ks
with a match some do not mention a 401k
at all now my understanding is that you
have to begin withdrawing from a 401k at
a certain age and I'm wondering if at my
age would I even be allowed to put money
into a
401k and uh if I did
what would I do put the put the money in
the 401K and get the employer match and
then start withdrawing the
401K well truthfully Bill bills I don't
want to be there bare bad news but we
got a ways to go before we would even
begin investing so we wouldn't recommend
you do any investing until you clean up
this
mess even with the uh even with the
employer match even with the employer
match you guys are so underwater on
payments you don't have a dime to invest
you're exactly right so we need to clean
up this debt and so I'm going to start
with the smallest balance the largest
I'm going to try to can your daughter
make the payment on these student loans
she won't do it why she says it's the
parents responsibility to pay for the
child's education I all my education who
taught her that
Mom uh how did you guess oh my goodness
well okay so Bill here's the reality
you've been catered to her whole life
well this is as much a marital problem
as much as a financial yeah you you got
some resentment towards towards your
spouse yeah you you got a marriage issue
and George and I can't solve the
marriage issue unfortunately the
marriage issue has created a mountain of
money issues and um bill look here's the
bottom line we teach the baby steps for
a reason whether you're 71 51 or 31 and
right now what you have to do is $1,000
as an emergency fund and unfortunately
you had a massive emergency in the form
of an HVAC system you got to take care
of that George that's uh that's a tough
situation uh you can't you can't use
credit cards to do that um but you guys
are going to have to scramble and work
and uh it's time for you and Mom to have
a conversation with the daughter and
it's time for her to grow up that's
going to be a difficult conversation if
your wife is as concerned as you said
she is then it's time for her to have
some hard conversations this is a mess
yeah I mean you're looking at that
200,000 outside of the mortgage that you
guys owe if you're taking on these
Parent Plus Loans while making 90 and
you're already almost 72 Bill and so
we've got to make some big decisions you
got to go make 25 bucks an hour at least
40 hours a week to help but you need
your wife on the same page first you're
not going to make any progress when
you're trying to do this on your own and
you need to have that hard conversation
with your daughter and say listen mom
and dad are broke and if unless you want
to be taken care of us for the next 20
years we need to clean up our mess and
you need to clean up these student loans
but again the legal responsibility is on
you guys which is the worst part about
these Parent Plus Loans Ken High
interest rates for barents the kid
doesn't pay it's on the parents and uh
Thanksgiving dinner is real awkward Bill
I'm so sorry you're going through this
man I hope that you can clean this up
and one day retire again but this time
the right way with some dignity with
some peace with some patience and with a
pile of money create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life